i'm not saying that real estate is the
only channel of investment that the
person need to do but i think for sure
it must be a part of his portfolio
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
and meet divir milo dvr started his
career in corporates like partner and
converse he was the co-founder and cto
for eventing israel the second largest
ticketing platform and company in the
world selling more than 300 million
tickets a year
in the last five years at event team he
was the vice president of machine
learning product for the entire group
building complex products based on big
data and machine learning and leading as
cto the first ever offshore r d center
for eventing for the last two years he's
been the cto for home 365 growing from
four developers to 40 employees
there is thrilled to have the option to
change completely the property
management market and make it tech based
accurate easy and transparent
i'm excited to talk to you about two two
incredible companies of which your
cto event team home 365. i'm excited to
talk to you about
leadership in tech growing tech teams
from very very small to to larger um
working with data along the way but
really building building phenomenal
products
as um as a the engineering manager and
what have you learned about you know
being an engineering manager uh not just
a team leader but but growing and and
nurturing
an org and on the organization from the
get-go
with two very very cool companies and so
thank you very much for being here and
i'm looking forward to it
great again thank you for having me
um if i need to to speak about what i
learned in a nutshell in the last uh 12
years that i've been in studio for 13
years actually and that i've been cto
for growing companies is one you need to
understand your audience and what you're
trying to get in in each phase
go to market
the first time and having a
top
niche
tech
product that will serve or change the
market because actually both in event
team and and in on 365 we are
changing the way and that's what
exciting me the most because we are
changing the way that people interact uh
at event image was buying and purchasing
uh at the same time tickets or their uh
football or basketball team tickets and
in om365 we are changing the way of our
most
precious place which is home i'm leaving
it my home i'm
you know in every other industry i can
do so many things from my living room
book a
tourist guide in
morocco or
having a
surf
surf trip in
sri lanka but to interact with my
homeowner or to have a service provider
that will come and and fix my leaking
thing it's uh it's a veal de la rosa a
very hard task to do and a lot of stuff
and we are changing the way that people
interact with with their own or with
their
day-to-day uh tasks that they need to do
with their home and this is what
exciting me the most and and coming back
to what
i've learned is first is to focus on
your audience and what you want to
achieve in every target so i i always
have a plan for the first year what i
want to achieve
i uh on the second year you know the
third year i'm writing in me for really
on a small note and putting it in my
wallet and from time to time every at
least every month i'm taking a look at
my uh at my notes and targets and and
checking myself if i if i achieve them
and do everything in my power to to
achieve them
um
and and that's the way uh i i'm used to
work and and
i
make sure that i fulfill my my targets
and my goals
second
i really believe her that
a product cannot be
perfect from from the start
you cannot aim for a
perfect product with all the features
that you just can imagine and and you
need to focus on the mvp what's most
important for you what you like the
the first uh the first phase your user
to achieve
what they you wanted them to do
and in course of time
keep your product better and better from
the tech side from the feature side from
the user experience side
of course i'm not saying that it's not
supposed to be perfect for every feature
that you are already developing and have
a great experience for the user because
a user that will come and have a
not a great experience
most likely won't come back
so
you want to do everything that that you
do
perfectly but it does not saying that
you need the full monty uh product from
day one
and from my knowledge products that grow
every year every month every sprint
whatever you like to measure by
and and being mature in phases
become great products in time
and and and guys and tech teams that are
trying to focus and aim to be the first
the perfect from day one
will
fail from one of the two reasons they
will deliver it too late or
they will
deliver too much too soon
and with the too much too soon there
there is problems that a product that is
not mature as i said people will come
not using it
and you know
you will lose a customer which is in my
point of view the most important thing
that you can acquire is is a customer
satisfaction and and what exciting me
did i get a feedback from users that
saying wow it changed the way
we interact with in a specific market
so you're obviously very attracted to
the to the high level strategy of you
know what is expected of you as a
technology leader and and how do you fit
into the whole construct of the company
at the same time you're also very detail
oriented and and you're looking at at
the agility and you're looking at the
priorities and and really what your task
is
for for looking at the the zero to one
phase
where you're taking event team and home
365 and you're sort of building this
from the ground up and you're building
this
this this um you know this new idea this
new
organization
that is going to be running technology
for this idea
what what have you learned
what are what are some things that have
happened that have taught you
you know about tech leadership
that that were non-trivial for you
before
you know i am a people person and and i
learned that there are a lot of great
engineers
but you need a strong team players in
order to succeed especially
uh in in structure small teams because
this
makes the difference
when you have great team members and and
great team leaders or director or group
leaders whatever with you alone because
you cannot win by yourself forget it if
you think that it's
that technology is a one-man show
uh you know i skip it try it try another
field you need a strong team
and and
trying to identify when you're building
and structures the team and the first
members of the team
try to find the team members the the the
guys that are
doing you know long runs and not
switching between companies every
five months or one year or one and a
half years and really invest their time
in
in a while
in order to prove themselves that they
can do
uh hard tasks or challenging uh
features
and if you will succeed to find this
core team players
you know the the way to success is quite
promising to you because if you will
need
to switch every now and then your team
members and you lose the knowledge and
and you lose the ability to to excel
as a company
you will fail you will fail because you
the great ideas
there are a lot without great ideas you
cannot do nothing but without a great
team even you if you will have the most
advanced and the most
innovative uh
tech company
without a strong team a devoted a
devoted team
a team that is not
know the word failure you see only
success you see only the positive things
or you see only
how
you know the can do approach that
sometimes sounds like a slogan
i really a strong believer because when
you ask people and they will
explain to you
how you can achieve your target how you
can achieve it
and there are a lot of difficult the the
difficulties uh along the way you know
not everything is smooth not
everything's walk from from the first
try you will fail uh and this is another
thing that i've learned across along the
way you need to fail in order to succeed
you need to fail in some features you
need to fail in some technologies you
are using in
an article in an architecture you are
using from your own failure or from
other people failure so you need to
listen to be a good listener as well but
in order to succeed you need
to be
brave enough and to to dare and to try
new stuff
to listen to your team members
and and
to to get them to feel a part
of uh of
of your challenge of your vision of what
you're trying to aim
and once you have this school
three four five people that are
going shoulder to shoulder with you
with whatever your dreams and whatever
you want to try
the second stage to to grow the team to
that to 50 to 100 people will be much
much easier much much easier you know no
you cannot have
a team of 100 engineers or more that
everybody is perfect and doing
everything uh in uh
anything in any in every field but the
core team that the four or five first
members
are the most important ones that that
can
you know
decide for you if you fail or
succeed big
and so as you're scaling the team and
you're obviously you know working
alongside the the ceo and the other
executive team
how do you how do you know when it's the
right time for you to grow
your team members is it sort of this
indefinite let's always hire and always
grow or is it
you know per per need
or per
you know per funding ground i mean how
do you how do you personally in home 365
make those decisions
it's it's a great question um
and i had a lot of discussion with with
the
company ceo
shakir about that and both of us
actually are likely to have him
supporting me and
and this is his vision as well
not to hire a lot of tech companies like
to hire people for no need
first of all he damage you in a way that
people coming and you don't and they
don't have tasks to do so right why why
doing that and if you're too short on
your fund and your burn rates don't do
that because
you need to feel responsible
for people first of all the employees
are people that left their job
chose you
to follow the the your dream or the
vision that that you that that you gave
them and and sometimes
left their jobs
and and and
gave them
gave you their time and i'm feeling very
responsible for people and i won't hire
anyone just to make me feel good and
tell to my vcs or to my i don't know um
uh
customers or to my opponent that i'm
growing big to 50 for no reason just to
make me feel good okay ego good
i um
we are we grew
when we had the need either it was okay
we prove our product
for example market fit
the the market loves it and now in order
to to scale
we we need i don't know this feature and
this 20 or 50 features and to have them
fast i'm i i need
10 or 20 new developers
and it's not just i'm i'm taking them to
to two or three months journey i will
neither in the future because if it's
for two three four five months journey i
would hire you know a subcontractor that
that will just i i
always look on the long run and i always
when i hire someone i i know in my heart
that i will have at least two years
of
job or
features to to give him
and you know we have other property
companies in attacking the market they
are that's
with half of the customers are
twice of three or three times bigger
than us
and you know we have
and we and we are after round b we have
the money to grow really big but we are
doing it step by step
very cautious
uh
very
mindful to people to the real features
that we wanna that we wanna
prepare we not just preparing features
we are preparing our our infrastructure
for the next phases to scale because
it's all different story to serve 7 7
500 properties or to serve 20 000
properties like we wanted to do a year
from now and we our goal is to grow
as big as uh
100 000
com properties in in two three years top
so
incredible and so
365 properties home 365. tell me a
little bit about sort of this pain point
and how
you know the technology that you're
building
is
making an impact there
so
first of all if you look in the property
management
industry
most of it is
doing total manual work it's moms and
pops
companies that are working with no dad
they giving their they're giving their
uh
they're giving their uh
their uh
home owners data by
sending it sending them by email or you
know what's up pictures
uh so ninety percent are non-tech
companies
a really tech company use a google sheet
or or excel in the in the good in a good
way
we are doing two things to this market
first of all introduce technology
not on the accounting side because there
are some big companies that are doing
the accounting for sure we are doing the
accounting one of the core features that
we want to do is
uh
you know the ability to uh collect rent
from tenants and pay
their owners their share and and stuff
like that but we are doing it in a tech
way transparent efficient so an owner
for example that sits in italy and have
a property in las vegas can
take a look in his owner app and in
every time of every hour he can see what
what his property made for him what is
his our eye
and what happened in the property in a
way of maintenance for example just
imagine yourself that you are sitting in
a in your property as a tenant and you
have a leaking sync like i mentioned
before what what you're doing now so
yeah i tried to call try to understand
who to call first of all and the guy
that gave you an offer is it fair not
fair
with our solution end-to-end all
technology talent have an app openly
open is app taking a video
our machine learning model take the
video split it to a lot of
frames and trying to to find objects
that we recognize on the other hand he
uh recognizes the voice and and and from
the voice
trying to find sentences uh that that
you know
try to find a problem from a moment that
tenant says for example a talent is
taking a picture of a guard off a garden
you will say okay let's send him a
gardener you have a problem with his
garden no but he mentioned that he have
bugs in his garden or rats in his garden
so i need to send him exterminator
another machine learning model tried to
find the best vendors for him that is
most reliable fair on the price uh
not having you know uh recurring issues
after we fix something leave their the
property clean
uh and then we find the vector and all
the scheduling is done through the app
when i'm coming when it's completely
convenient for you
so a to z
all the communication is done by
technology and an owner that sits in
italy see everything everything is
transparent and he feel confident that
his property that he was saving for so
uh when so hard work is in in good end
so first thing is technology the second
is
our business model which is actually
amazing thing if you will think about it
there are two things that that you know
bother
property or real estate investor one of
them
is uh
maintenance issues
for example water reader that
gone
broke uh to replace it five thousand
dollars it's like
four month rent
that you need to you know
it's out of your calculation
second thing is vacancies you have a
tenant that are not living in the in the
property you will you got a mortgage or
a loan to buy this property and now you
need to take out the pocket money and
you don't have any income
and again with data and with a lot
of uh algorithms that we are doing by
data that we have on properties data
that we have made and other data like
geographic data and other amazing stuff
we build a machine learning algorithm
that try to predict
what is on 365 risk
in
managing a property and by doing that we
can offer
uh
peace of mind
for the property owner so we have
like uh
premium uh premium plans where we offer
the owners
to
invest and rest
we will promise you a specific
return on investment
for sure you will pay on it more every
month but
you will have a peace of mind and we are
making
the
real estate investment predictable
and
peace of mind
a little bit a little bit into the
zillow world right leveraging leveraging
different algorithms to be able to
to then
have an engagement a meaningful
engagement with the real estate whether
it's a you know zillow was purchasing
here it's it's management but but
effectively it's underwriting some asset
yeah yeah exactly we are between
proptech insuretech and fintech we are
the three of them a mixture of mashup of
the three of them and and you know we
are
again changing the way that this that
that is work because
we are professional in property
management okay
do you want to be an investor let's
professional manage your asset your one
of your most important assets
we will guarantee
if you will have a vacant property we
will pay the rent instead of the tenant
that left you and if you will have a big
uh
maintenance issue
you will pay a deductible like like in
an insurance company and we will cover
the rest so it gives you peace of mind
it gives you the ability to predict
your roi monthly or really whatever you
want to plan that and and it gives you
peace of mind that you can inject it and
you know we remove the barriers that
prevent from so many people to invest in
real estate and i'm not saying that real
estate is the only channel of investment
that the person need to do but i think
for sure it must be a part of his
portfolio
well
really really cool i think that
um both the venti and home 365
extremely cool ways you you're entering
technology into
you know very very old-school type of uh
of engagements that we have as consumers
but
really rethinking a lot of these models
and premises and where these assumptions
that we start whether we start with as
we're approaching these industries and
so uh
very cool on the technological front
very cool on the on the leadership and
business model front and and i really
want to thank you for for coming here a
very very enjoyable 20 minutes
definitely sparked curiosity there and
i'm going to spend some time diving into
the prop tech and ensure that world
myself and thank you very much for your
time
thank you again and thank you for
listening to us and and you know have
always
you know dare to to try new stuff new
new technologies news new methods
because you will always you know
be a winner
thank you very much for your time as
well
[Music]